how you frame your past is a choice that
we all have we can look through the lens
of the rear view mirror with regret or
shame or we can look at it with
gratitude and we have a choice to kind
of mine meaning out of that experience
I'm now in a place that I never thought
I would be that I never imagined for
myself I didn't vision board it and yet
it suits me so perfectly well in that I
get to engage with my curiosity and my
creativity I get to grow in the process
and I get to give back which is as much
as I could ask you know I I wouldn't
change anything as as painful as some of
those chapters were they were ultimately
necessary you know Stepping Stones on
the path to you know being where I am
today and and I would surmise that you
would
respond the same